forty miles southwest of Tucson between
Arizona's ko bokja very mountains is an
Old West Ranch town like no other cow
town Calaca was built by this man at
keylock oh that's Edward JB kiraku
all with his bare hands that's right
[Music]
like in the Old West town couch ancilla
girl has a church a bank a cemetery and
a saloon but unlike most other Old West
towns this cow town is still standing
all because of this man
God drank to death I believe everything
here everything you see around here
we're done with a small truck
I hate new machinery that figure I
didn't do it even that water tower that
one their whole ever a pickup truck why
exactly did Edward JB kulikov build his
own town Eadie born to a black mother
and white father I was orphaned at a
young age in Jim Crow America my
childhood was rough I was light-skinned
red hair green eyes remember a young kid
climb the tree runs he's over here looks
up a mess up here I'm up here and he
urinated in my face and those are the
kind of things that you'd have to live
with as you if you look like me these
hardships he let go developed his
independent frontier spirit wouldn't you
say so it a pattern my own canoe like
they say in the West sat on my own Bronk
I wrote it out ident under this with
this lesson in mind ed constructed an
Old West utopia four decades later
cotton continues its celebration of
individuality with a biannual event
known as Kela Cody's people like to come
to cotton
no hay should hear no racism except you
who you are you can dream of things that
never were and say why not that's the
way I my mind thinks a lot of people
thought I was crazy I said well maybe I
am
they ran
[Music]
you
[Music]